après avoir été relogées dans cette
chambre rené s'apprête à retrouver son
appartement
celui là même qui avait été sinistrée
suite à l'incendié d'un immeuble
vendredi dernier a besoin de ça lisez et
vous à faire elles sont ou encore toubab
h les mois voire les taxes est quant à
lui rentré comme lui
54 adultes et 42 enfants vont regagner
leur domicile
certains auront passé trois jours dans
ce foyer pour jeunes travailleurs
nous avons pu accueillir sept personnes
et les le nourrir aussi le week-end en
faisant un système d'exception puisque
le self est fermé à partir de samedi à
midi mais nous avons fait des plateaux
et des sandwichs pour qu'il puisse avoir
un repas le soir midi et soir une
réunion est prévue dans l'après-midi
pour organiser les modalités du retour
des résidents dans l'immeuble incendié
une mission délicate les sinistrés n'ont
pas tous été relogés au même endroit on
savait qu'il y avait des personnes en
vacances qui étaient hébergés chez des
dents de la famille chez des tiers
la solidarité a joué aussi sur le
quartier de ksar soleil donc il ya eu
des solutions apportées à l'interné par
par les ménages selon les services de la
ville cette opération de relogement aura
sans doute été la plus importante jamais
entreprise à besançon